hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt jetzt denkt ihr wahrscheinlich
winters machte denn hier hinter der
küchentheke wachstumsraten sind kuchen
ja ich backe noch als eher hinten steht
eine leckere torte das ist aber das
kommt erst in ein paar wochen nämlich
für die globus aktion backen mit loos
und silly ein neues rezept aber darüber
wollte ich es gar nicht sprechen wir
sind gerade noch mitten im filmen da
vorne machte markus gerade noch ein paar
fotos von meinen torten und ich wollte
euch über die messe informieren jetzt am
wochenende in hannover
also in hannover ist die infomesse das
ist eine kreativ messe und dort wird
auch für drei tage die kate world
stattfinden also auf der infomesse und
da sind wir natürlich wieder mit dabei
morath ich und mein gesamtes team mit
job und ich werde dort drei tage für
euch da sein und kochen und backen und
jungen ist gefunden und ist was
probieren natürlich kostenlos wir haben
getränke für euch und im prinzip ist es
wie auf jeder messe das heißt ich bin
von morgens bis abends da ein
unterschied das erste mal ist dieses mal
nicht dabei
letztes jahr war sie immer im bauch mit
dabei und dieses jahr war sie live so
mit dabei und jetzt ist ja aber echt
schon zu groß und sie darf dann ein paar
tage bei oma opa bleiben die freuen sich
schon sehr
und das ist auch für die kleine und für
uns natürlich viel besser
ja und was werden wir machen uns noch
als riesengroßes riesiger ist die
handwerkermesse dabei die ist einfach
aber einer der größten messen in
deutschland ich glaube es war wenn ich
die größte verbrauchermesse ich glaube
auch workshops und so weiter
alles da gibt es auch an kreativ abend
am samstag direkt genau wurde ich auch
schon gefragt ob ich dabei bin aber
vielleicht vielleicht aber haben acht
stunden messetag nun schon hinter uns
müssen wir mal schauen
jedenfalls wollte ich euch noch kurz zum
ablauf sagen also ihr bekommt natürlich
online noch karten also vorverkauf aber
natürlich auch direkt an der kasse als
dem ist jetzt nicht online noch bestellt
sondern ihr könnt sie direkt an der
kasse holen und es sind genügend karten
da und die messe ist wirklich riesengroß
das heißt schaut nicht nur bei uns am
stand vorbei sondern auch auf ganz
vielen anderen
und bei uns zu sein also bisher war es
immer so dass ich morgens in die küche
gegangen bin in meiner seele küche und
dann einfach ein bisschen was gekocht
und gebacken habe danach ganz
autogrammstunde und fotos mit mir dann
mal wieder in die küche
aber natürlich mit steigender
abonnentenzahl sage ich jetzt mal ist
natürlich so gewesen auf den letzten
messen dass ich eigentlich die größte
zeit immer bei den fotos und autogrammen
verbracht habe was ihn natürlich sehr
schön finde reicht da den kontakt zu
euch habt und euch mal kennenlernen kann
wenn auch nur kurz aber es tut mir
natürlich sehr leid für alle diejenigen
die gekommen sind um mich kochen backen
zu sehen
und dieses mal werden wir das ein
bisschen geplante machen und
strukturierter machen und werden morgen
um 10 anfangen mit einer koch und back
show das heißt ich steht dann in der
küche ihr könnt mir live dabei zuschauen
und auch probieren und mir währenddessen
fragen stellen was euch schon immer mal
interessiert hat moratti stadt auch mit
dabei und hab ich da etwas vergessen
ja es ist einmalig wie möglich alle
nokia zu geben genau das ist leider
nicht mehr möglich allen autogramme zu
geben also werden auch letzte woche auf
der autogrammstunde im globus
rüsselsheim gemerkt so einfach so viel
los wir haben schon eine halbe stunde
früher angefangen und statt zwei stunden
wurden daraus vier stunden oder
viereinhalb sie sogar und das auch nur
weil wir weil irgendwann einfach
abgesperrt wurde denn sonst wäre die
autogramm schon länger gegangen als die
öffnungszeit des ladens und das hat
natürlich nicht gegangen hätte mir
abschließende liebe ist es so dass man
den leuten redet und ihre fragen stellen
anstatt autogramme jahre ist zwar cool
alles aber ich hab da am ende nichts
davon
ein autogramm ich finde es eigentlich
gar nichts wert sondern es ist viel
besser wenn ihr mit mir reden können
mich kennenlernen können und das kann
ich eben nur machen wenn ich in der
küche stehe weil wir ansonsten nicht die
zeit haben für jeden einzelnen und
deswegen werden wir eben in der küche
starten eineinhalb stunden und dann
bekomme ich kurz mikrofone weg und dann
geht es in die autogrammstunde das
machen wir dann eine stunde und danach
gibt es eine kurze pause dass jeder sich
für das sammeln kann und dann machen wir
die zweite kurve tun die ganze zeit
kochen backen genau als auch im stand
gibt es immer was zu essen
es ist alles nur kostenlos wir haben
extra viele viele unternehmen
angeschrieben und goodies zu bekommen da
und dürfen euch kostenlose geschenke
verteilt da haben uns sich daran gemacht
und überall angehoben hat ob sie zwar
auf dem messe unterstützen
ganz viele leckere sachen ganze längst
alles alles kostenlos wer die männer
kriegen wieder als männer und frauen
kriegen natürlich auch wieder kaffee
cappuccino heiße schokolade und getränke
werden wir euch auch anbieten was jetzt
auch ganz cool ist das verraten was auf
der messe ist eine weltpremiere auf der
messe geben
ja und zwar habe ich da nicht drüber zu
hause aber mein neues buch wird es auf
der messe ergeben und so nicht mal
daheim nicht mehr als heute morgen erst
einmal auf der messe sehr heute morgen
wurde es in den shop geliefert und aus
dem lkw direkt vom versand dienst wurde
es gleich in unseren lkw geladen und ist
schon auf dem weg zur messe und ich habe
wirklich selber noch nicht in der hand
gehabt ich werde dann gleich beim aufbau
gleich mal auspacken und mir anschauen
aber dort geht es dann das buch online
in unserem onlineshop gibt es aber erst
ende oktober genau weil es ist ob ich es
ist ein druck wir haben ein paar
exemplare ist mit vielleicht genug ist
ein plan her sowieso nicht auf jeden
fall am park konnten wir schon mal raus
holen außer drei ganz druckfrisch noch
warm wahrscheinlich dann was wird es
noch geben was gibt's noch ein schönes
back rahmen und back ringe und so weiter
auch liegt das backblech wird auch da
sehr genau und das wacklig ist auch ganz
neu ist dann auch auf der messe das
erste auch über nicht gesehen oder einen
und ein produkt ob ich hier und was mich
auch immer ganz viele fragen ist ein
ganzer schock dar
nein ist er natürlich nicht aber ihr
bekommt gutscheine für den online-shop
weil wir einfach nicht alles herr
bringen können und auch nicht der platz
dafür daher wird dann ist natürlich
roger moore ist genau es gibt auch mit
kitchen mini zu gewinnen
es gibt auch zum ersten mal wieder eine
premiere nach
dann gibt es einen ganz coolen typen
wettbewerb das bestimmt cakewalk gibt es
ein wettbewerb wo der erste preis ist
eine kitschige was jetzt doch ja
ansonsten gibt den murat ja ich werde
auch autogramme geben weil das ihr job
ich darf ab und sagt wie ein autogramm
geben meine auto-kommission wertvoller
als die vorderzähne weil wir sind wie
selten
dann muss ich fragen wie die leute
kommen ja okay gibt es eigentlich so
ziemlich alles gesagt
die messe geht von 15 17 also samstag
sonntag und montag
und wie gesagt seid nicht traurig weil
wir jetzt nicht jedem ein autogramm
geben können aber wie gesagt ich finde
es schöner wenn wir uns einfach so
persönlich unterhalten können und ich
hoffe ihr habt verständnis dafür genau
nicht allen recht machen
weiters ist das ganze also alle spaß
haben
ja ich freue mich vor allem ganz arg auf
die messe weil es ist die letzte messe
in diesem jahr also ist nicht deswegen
so ist ja deswegen gebe es noch sehr
viele andere leute auf der messe aus dem
fernsehen sind viele leute vorbei
jedenfalls machen wir hier jetzt noch
unser video fertig oder genau und was
das kind noch nie fragen gewesen sein
was keine ahnung
falls eine frage ist könnte es auch
gerne die wahrheitsfrage der zuschauer
genau sagt man wo kann man in hannover
gut essen genau den tipp könnte noch
geben
günstig ist wahrscheinlich fragte am
besten empfiehlt ihrem rat und
schwäbische maultaschen restaurant okay
dann freuen wir uns schon sehr auf die
messe und hoffen dass ihr da seid wir
sind auf jeden fall mit dabei werden
auch schon früher anreisen und die messe
auf bayern wir warten wir fahren los um
freitagmorgen also morgen früh um eine
familie also freitagfrüh um ein uhr
morgens pünktlich da simma franken
generell baumhof wenn sven 30 40 leute
zeit haben uns beim aufbau zu helfen
dreieck
einfach vorbeikommen
samstag sonntag und montag vor kaczynski
vielleicht wird uns helfen
ok